WHY IT MIGHT BE HARD TO TURN
THAT SPIGOT OFF.
BUT FIRST, MY THOUGHTS AT THE
END OF DAY 35, AMERICA IN
SHUTDOWN.
DEMOCRATS TAKING THE VIRAL PATH
TO SOCIALISM.
YOU FEEL IT, DON’T YOU?
AND YOU SEE IT.
YOU SENSE IT.
THERE’S A GROWING DIVIDE IN
AMERICA IN THIS COVID-19 ERA AND
I’M TALKING -- NOT TALKING ABOUT
RICH OR POOR OR BLACK VERSUS
WHITE OR EVEN RED STATE VERSUS
BLUE STATE.
I’M TALKING ABOUT THE GROWING
TENSION BETWEEN THE OPEN NOW
COALITION VERSUS THE STAY CLOSED
IN PERPETUITY CONTINGENT.
THE ANGLE TOLD YOU WEEKS AGO
THAT IF PEOPLE BEGAN TO SEE THE
GOVERNMENT’S RESPONSE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS AS MORE TOXIC THAN
THE VIRUS ITSELF, WELL, THINGS
WOULD START TO GET HEATED.
THAT’S WHAT WE’VE BEEN SEEING
OVER THE PAST WEEK OR SO.
>> WE ARE STARTING TO DIE
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMY.
>> I’M PROTESTING THE SLOW
EROSION OF OUR LIFE.
BECAUSE WE ARE JUST HERE FOR OUR
FREEDOM.
PEOPLE NEED TO GET BACK TO WORK.
>> IT’S ABOUT YOUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
>> WE ARE BEING MUZZLED BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
DON’T LET THEM ASK THAT YOU WEAR
TURN INTO THAT MUSCLE.
>> Laura: A PRESIDENT EVEN
CHIMED IN YESTERDAY.
>> IT DOESN’T FEEL THAT WAY,
YOU’RE ALLOWED TO PROTEST.
THEY FEEL THAT WAY.
I WATCH THE PROTEST ON THEY WERE
ALL 6 FEET APART.
I BET IT WAS A VERY ORDERLY
GROUP OF PEOPLE, BUT YOU KNOW,
SOME, SOME HAVE GONE TOO FAR.
SOME GOVERNORS HAVE GONE TOO FAR
FAR.
>> Laura: THE FOLKS PROTESTING
THE STAY-AT-HOME ORDERS ARE
MOSTLY SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS,
THEIR MOMS, THEIR DADS, STUDENTS
EVEN, WHO ARE SEEING THEIR
FUTURES GO DOWN THE DRAIN.
OF COURSE THEY’RE WORRIED ABOUT
THEIR FELLOW MAN.
OF COURSE THEY WANT TO KEEP THE
VULNERABLE, THE ELDERLY SAFE AND
SECURE.
BUT THEY ALSO COMPLAIN ABOUT
NEEDLESS AND ARBITRARY RULES
THAT DECLARE BIKE STORES
ESSENTIAL, BUT NOT CHURCHES.
NOW, THIS VIDEO WAS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MORE DISTURBING VISUALS
FROM THE LAST WEEKEND.
OFFICIALS IN SAN CLEMENTE POURED
37 TONS OF SAND INTO RALPH’S
SKATE COURT AFTER SKATEBOARDERS
WERE CAUGHT ROUTINELY IGNORING
THE NO TRESPASSING SIGN.
THIS IS KIND OF PATHETIC, DON’T
YOU THINK?
ARE TEENS GETTING SUNSHINE AND
ZOOMING PAST EACH OTHER REALLY
THE PROBLEM HERE, THE BIG THREAT
TO CIVILIZATION?
I GUESS MAYBE -- I DON’T KNOW.
BUT OVER THE WEEKEND WE LEARNED
THAT GOVERNMENT RESEARCHERS HAVE
FOUND THAT SIMULATED SUNLIGHT
RAPIDLY KILL THE VIRUS AND
AEROSOL.
SUNLIGHT COULD ACTUALLY KILL IT.
LIKE MOM ALWAYS SAID, FRESH AIR
AND SUNSHINE REALLY IS THE BEST
DISINFECTANT.
BUT EVEN IF YOU WHO DO SOCIALLY
DISTANCE IN CALIFORNIA,
REMEMBER, YOU SOCIALLY DISTANCE,
BUT YOU CAN STILL BE SNITCHED
UPON.
>> IF YOU’VE OBSERVED OCCURRING
VIOLATIONS OF THE STAY-AT-HOME
ORDER, PLEASE CONTINUE TO LET US
KNOW AT CORONAVIRUS DOT L.A.
CITY.ORG/BUSINESS VIOLATION.
YOU KNOW THE OLD EXPRESSION
ABOUT SNITCHES.
IN THIS CASE, SNITCHES GET
REWARDS.
>> Laura: SNITCHES GET
THAT ONE COMMENT TOLD YOU
EVERYTHING YOU NEED TO KNOW
ABOUT HOW FAR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ARE ACTUALLY WILLING TO GO TO
ENFORCE A NEW NORMAL, A PHRASE I
DESPISED, BECAUSE A NEW NORMAL
MEANS CIVIL LIBERTIES BE DAMNED,
BUT EVEN WHEN SNITCHES AREN’T
SNATCHING, WATCH YOURSELF,
BECAUSE DRONES ARE FLYING
OVERHEAD.
>> THE DRONES MAKE IT EASIER FOR
POLICE TO SEE INTO CERTAIN AREAS
WHERE ACCESS BY PATROL CARS IS
MORE DIFFICULT.
>> THAT INCLUDES TIGHT SPACES
BETWEEN BUILDINGS, BEHIND
SCHOOLS AND IN BACKYARDS.
THE DRONES, DONATED BY DJI, A
CHINESE COMPANY, HAVE GONE TO 43
AGENCIES IN 22 STATES.
>> Laura: CHINESE AFFILIATED
RHONE COMPANY.
[LAUGHS]
TO THAT, I’M NOT SAYING OUR
BROTHER.
I’M SAYING OH BIG BROTHER.
BEYOND THE NOBLE MOTIVES OF
KEEPING AMERICANS SAFE AND FREE
AT THE SAME TIME, THE IGNOBLE
GOAL OF USING THIS CRISIS TO
REMAKE AMERICAN SOCIETY
ACCORDING TO MORE PROGRESSIVE
IDEALS.
>> LET’S USE THIS SITUATION,
THIS CRISIS, THIS TIME, TO
ACTUALLY LEARN THE LESSONS,
VALUE FROM THE REFLECTION AND
LET’S REIMAGINE WHAT WE WANT
SOCIETY TO BE.
HOW DO WE HAVE A BETTER
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM, BETTER
HOUSING SYSTEM, BETTER PUBLIC
SAFETY SYSTEM, BETTER HEALTH
SYSTEM, BETTER SOCIAL EQUITY?
AND LET’S USE THIS AS A MOMENT
TO REALLY PLAN, CHANGE THAT WE
COULD NORMALLY NEVER DO UNLESS
YOU HAD THIS SITUATION.
>> Laura: THAT’S IT, CHANGE
YOU CAN NEVER DO IF YOU ACTUALLY
HAD TO RUN IT BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE, PERHAPS.
OR MAYBE HE’S JUST TALKING ABOUT
IMPROVING THE STATE GOVERNMENT’S
RESPONSE TO FUTURE, HEAVEN
FORBID, PANDEMICS.
THAT WOULD BE FINE.
WELL, THAT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
TAKING A HARD LOOK AT WHY YOUR
STATE BUDGET ORDERS NEXT
VENTILATORS.
IN FAVOR OF SOCIAL WELFARE
PROJECTS.
MEANWHILE, YOU GET THE SENSE
THAT SOMEONE OUT THERE IS
FEELING A LITTLE LEFT OUT IN
THIS COVID CRISIS, BECAUSE SHE’S
STREAMING UP A STORM AND
INSTAGRAM.
>> INCREMENTALISM IS NOT HELPFUL
IN THIS MOMENT.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DEMAND MEANINGFUL CHANGE AND
MEANINGFUL ASSISTANCE FOR
WORKING FAMILIES.
THAT MEANS 2,000 A MONTH, PLUS A
THOUSAND FOR YOUR KIDS
RECURRING.
>> Laura: THAT’S A PRETTY GOOD
AMOUNT, 2,000 A MONTH.
WHY STOP -- 5,000 A WEEK!
DO I HEAR SIX?
ON THE LEFT COAST THOUGH, THEY
ARE NOT ALL ABOUT TO BE OUTDONE
BY THE NEW YORKERS, BECAUSE
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM HAS HIS OW
IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO USE THE
SHUTDOWN TO OPEN UP A PATH OF
NEW CLIMATE CHANGE POLICY.
HIS NEW TASK FORCE WILL BE
HEADED BY NONE OTHER THAN,
DRUMROLL PLEASE, THAT EVERY MAN,
TOM STEYER, THE BILLIONAIRE WHO
BELIEVES IN BANNING FOSSIL
FEELS, A WEALTH TAX AND SLAVERY
REPARATIONS.
HE SAYS THE GOAL OF THE
TASK FORCE IS TO RECOVER AS FAST
AND AS SAFELY AS POSSIBLE FROM
THE COVID-19-INDUCED RECESSION
AND TO CREATE A FAIR, GREEN, AND
PROSPEROUS FUTURE THAT REMEDIES
SOME OF THE INJUSTICES WHICH
THIS COVID-19 PANDEMIC HAS
REVEALED IN OUR SOCIETY.
THIS PANDEMIC HAS REVEALED A
LOT, ALL RIGHT, ABOUT CHINA,
ABOUT STATE PREPAREDNESS, ABOUT
THE INEPTITUDE OF THE CDC, AND
ABOUT DEMOCRATS’ UNWILLINGNESS
TO TOLERATE DISSENT.
BECAUSE IF YOU’RE SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVES THE SHUTDOWNS IN MOST
STATES NOW ARE HURTING IN MANY
CASES MORE THAN HELPING, WELL,
YOU’RE GOING TO BE LABELED A
PARIAH AND ANTISCIENCE.
AND HEAVEN FORBID IF YOU CHOOSE
TO EXERCISE YOUR FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHTS TO PEACEABLY PROTEST.
>> TRYING TO ORGANIZE SOMETHING
LIKE THAT -- QUALIFIED
INFORMATION.
>> WE DO CLASSIFY THAT AS
INFORMATION AND WE TAKE THAT
DOWN.
I THINK A LOT OF THE STUFF THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAYING AROUND A
HEALTH EMERGENCY LIKE THIS CAN
BE CLASSIFIED AS -- IS
MISINFORMATION.
>> Laura: HARMFUL
NOW, WHAT’S MORE TRUE HERE?
NEW YORK WILL NEED 30,000
VENTILATORS?
THAT SPARKED A LOT OF PANIC,
RIGHT?
WAS NOT HARMFUL?
OR THIS?
>> I THINK IT WAS THE WORST --
PROBABLY THE WORST WEEK OF MY
LIFE.
PRETTY MUCH LOOKING AT POSSIBLY
LOSING EVERYTHING WE’VE WORKED
FOR.
>> THE FIRST WEEK WE HAVE LOST
ALREADY 80% OF OUR INVENTORY.
>> RIGHT NOW WE ARE AT ZERO
EVERYWHERE.
I MEAN NO ONE -- IT’S EVEN WORSE
THAN I WOULD HAVE GUESSED.
>> Laura: SO IF THOSE FOLKS
WANTED TO SHOW UP AND PEACEABLY
PROTEST, THAT WOULD BE PART OF
THE HARMFUL DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN TO BE TAKEN DOWN FROM
FACEBOOK?
I NEED THE NEW RULES.
SO SNATCHING, SPYING WITH
DRONES, LIMITING SPEECH, CHASING
SURFERS OFF BEACHES OR
SKATEBOARDERS OUT OF SKATE
PARKS, WHERE THERE WERE A FEW
PROPORTIONALLY -- VERY FEW COVID
CASES.
NONE OF THAT SOUNDS VERY HEALING
TO ME.
AND THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE